will hong kong's new leader further
erode freedoms there john lee is the
former security chief who led to the
2019 crackdown on pro-democracy
protesters he's pledging to uphold the
rule of law
does that mean that china's grip on
britain's former colony is tightening
even further this is inside story
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
i'm nastasia tay now the result was a
foregone conclusion because there was
only one candidate to choose from
following a secret ballot hong kong has
a new leader john lee is due to replace
carrie lam as chief executive on july
1st now the staunch china loyalist was
elected by a committee of around 1 500
members all vetted to ensure their
patriotism to president xi jinping and
beijing now he says he wants to unify
society and make the asian financial hub
more competitive but activists in hong
kong say they fear that leaders in
beijing are further tightening their
grip adrian brown has more
with china's endorsement it was just a
question of how big john lee's winning
margin would be
to give the appearance of an open
contest the secret votes were presented
to the election committee before being
counted congratulations a landslide
1416 votes
in his acceptance speech lee promised to
lead a hong kong that was caring open
vibrant and vigilant
safeguarding our country's sovereignty
national security and development
interests
protecting hong kong from
internal and external threats and
ensuring its stability will continue to
be of parliament importance
the former number two in the hong kong
government had previously served as
security chief authorizing the use of
tear gas rubber bullets and occasional
live rounds to disperse protesters
during the unrest of 2019
it was an election day of one candidate
three protesters
and lots of police
seven thousand officers in fact enough
to keep the few dissenting voices well
away from the convention center where
the vote was held
analysts say that john lee has china's
trust but winning the trust of hong kong
could be more difficult trust can be
rebuilt through several ways one way
is by
restoring accountable government in hong
kong which has been debased i would say
under the
administration of cary lamb
so that requires the cooperation of the
media of legco
of civil society
sunday was also mother's day in hong
kong some people we spoke to were aware
there was an election but just weren't
sure of the candidate's name do you know
who won
uh john
oh i forgot his surname but yeah john so
you are aware of the chief executive
relationship yeah but do you know who
won the election sir there's only one
candidates
who else
hong kong people were supposed to choose
their leader for the first time in 2017.
it didn't happen then it hasn't happened
now raising the prospect that this could
be the model for future elections to
choose hong kong's leader
lee is due to be sworn in as chief
executive on july the first
traditionally a ceremony attended by
china's president
adrian brown for inside story
well you'll recall after 156 years of
colonial rule britain handed back
control of hong kong to china 25 years
ago
under the terms of the 1997 deal china
pledged to give the territory a high
degree of autonomy with its own
executive legislature and judiciary a
framework known as one country two
systems to last 50 years
leaders in beijing also agreed to
guarantee rights and freedoms for hong
kong's people including the right to
protest a free press and freedom of
speech
but then in recent years beijing has
cracked down on those freedoms stoking
mass protests and international
criticism in 2020 china voted to
introduce a national security law in
hong kong giving police broad powers to
punish critics and silence dissent
fundamentally changing life at seven
million people
they've had no say in who their new
leader is instead a committee of hong
kong's elite vetted by beijing chose him
in a one horse race
[Music]
well let's now bring in our guests in
hong kong we have tom grundy he is the
editor-in-chief and the founder of hong
kong free press and independent
publication in beijing viktor gao is a
chair professor at souchau university
and in nottingham in england steve sang
is the director of the china institute
at soast university of london welcome to
the program gentlemen thanks for being
with us today
steve i want to start with the process
that's just taking place uh an
appointment rather than an election it
seems this committee of electors very
much hand-picked do you feel like
there's now really been a move away from
even the attempted semblance of
democracy
i think you are right in saying that
what we have seen in hong kong is a
change from the past of a pretence to
elections
to now it is election in quotation marks
chinese style
the election
such an evol such as it was that took
place in hong kong really is no
different from
elections under the communist party
well victor let me bring you in here
because you yourself have been in the
corridors of power in beijing i
understand what is china's strategy here
well first of all let's congratulate mr
lee on becoming the next chief executive
of hong kong i think his election speaks
loudly that stability is restored in
hong kong and the society at large is
ready to embrace development and growth
as the principal challenge for the
residents in hong kong now for this
election to take place in hong kong
let's look at it in historical terms the
british colonists ruled hong kong for
more than 150 years they never elected
the governor of hong kong the governor
of hong kong has always been appointed
by the monarch and he did not represent
the people of hong kong he represented
the british bollock the imperialist
interests of hong kong therefore
whatever
grievances or complaints or
dissatisfaction you may
have you need to say that whatever
democratic rights in hong kong today is
already a far cry from the no democracy
at all before 1996
whether democracy can be further
enhanced and improved of course there
will be however no one can use democracy
or rule of law as a hiding shield to
promote the so-called independence of
hong kong or to deny the chinese
sovereignty over hong kong this is made
clear crystal clear now by mr lee's
election i think people in hong kong
will continue to practice capitalism
with hong kong style and they will be
very firmly committed to the one country
to system principle which will govern
hong kong up to 2047.
well we did see some
opposition i guess we could say three
protesters outside um and i understand
eight committee members i believe voted
against mr lee tom are you concerned
that there might be consequences for any
of those people
well who knows it's meant to be a secret
ballot there were also
um there were also four blank ballots uh
apparently but let's just look at the
numbers you know the facts of what just
happened today 1
461 voters in a city of 7 million
representing 0.02 percent of the public
um cast a ballot and
those people were vetted by none other
than a panel headed by john lee himself
last year he got a 99
uh support rate amongst these voters
uh and yet in the wider community he has
an approval rating of 37 according to
the last credible poll there were 7 000
police officers a lot of them assigned
to that protest you mentioned um today
that's almost five cops per voter and
all this cost the election budget over
this year is 30 million uh us dollars
and and just to respond there to to
victor it's very true british uh times
there was little intention to install
full democracy but there were attempts
made at democratic reforms in both the
50s and the 90s on their way out
which were quashed by beijing
um steve i want to bring you in here
because i could see that you didn't
necessarily agree um with mr gao um i'll
let you have the floor
if we deal with history as victor has
raised then we will have to deal with
history as facts rather than fiction
if we compare the last four british
governors with the four chief executives
since hong kong become chinese again
we can see that all four
of the last british governors
receive
very very high popular rating
there was no democratic
formal democratic accountability of the
british governors to hong kong but every
one of them was so responsive to public
opinions that every one of them receive
very high rating
none of that applies to the four chief
executives of hong kong
there was no british governor who had to
go to hong kong with 7 000 security
service people present to make sure that
there were no incidents that just
happened with the election of john lee
well coming back to present day i i want
to get to johnny in just a moment but i
also want to take a look at carrie
lamb's legacy you've spoken there steve
about approval ratings now i see carrie
lam is leaving officers the least
popular chief executive ever
33.4 percent approval i mean arguably it
was the 2019 protests that caused xi
jinping to harden his stance on hong
kong and much of that people believe was
due to lam's handling of the extradition
bill much of that driven some might
argue by her own political ambitions
tom you're in hong kong how will people
remember her
well um somewhat of a disastrous legacy
in that we have seen three news outlets
uh closed in the last year or two bear
in mind
um john lee was the number two official
right much of the last year and the
security chief before that overseeing
the protest
um 60 plus civil society groups
disbanded last year
most of the opposition the democrats are
either behind bars have fled into
ex-help exile or have quit politics
altogether we're seeing a mass exodus in
light of the national security law and
harsh coveted rules that lam has also
been accused of mishandling protests are
effectively illegal in the city at the
moment and
about a year ago
in the press freedom index hong kong was
was 80th and last week it saw the
biggest fall of any territory in the
world
to 148 so this is not only what johnny
is inheriting but also what he shares
responsibility for as a top official
throughout her tenure well let me throw
that then to victor
given the level of unpopularity of
carrie lam the legacy that she's left
and how she moved closer to beijing and
the perception of john lee is being very
close to beijing what challenges is he
likely to face trying to get hong
kongers on side
i think mr lee has huge challenges he
need to bring the society together he
need to reopen hong kong to
foreign business interests he hopefully
will need to visit the united states and
many other european countries and japan
and australia canada you name it to make
sure that hong kong is here to stay at
the one country to system will remain in
effect up to 2047 and hong kong will
continue to practice
capitalism with hong kong
characteristics with rule of law with
the hong kong dollar you've talked about
his engagement with various different
capitals i mean he can't set foot in the
u.s because he's sanctioned by the u.s
and obviously the crackdown in hong kong
has left a bit of taste in the mouth of
of many foreign leaders
i'm curious about where steve you think
this might be going in terms of how hong
kong is going to be perceived in the
eyes of the rest of the world and and
and how china is playing its cards here
well i think china just created
a moral hazard for
uh leaders of democratic democratic
countries in europe and in north america
if they accept john needs to visit
then they basically are telling
authoritarian countries in the world
that if they then make somebody who has
done something particularly odious
pretty put him in a position of
authority and whatever sanctions imposed
on that person will be lifted so this is
making it particularly impossible for
the united states government to allow
germany to visit the u.s and then we
will get into it and acrimony of the
chinese authorities accusing the u.s and
perhaps other western countries for
being hostile to hong kong because they
would not accept the chief executive of
hong kong we should never be in a
situation like that
i want to talk a little bit more about
john lee the man because it will affect
how he
sorry i i think both have referred to
you know hong kong's international
status here and john lee's promise to
restore its international standing none
of this is going to be possible for as
long as hong kong is pursuing what china
is in terms of a zero code or dynamic
zero um policy at the moment we have
masks on 24 7 seven days uh quarantine
in a hotel for any arrivals this is
meant to be asia's world city an
international city
hong kong is not going to be able to
change that and regain its status amid
this big brain drain and exodus unless
china changes its isolationist covid
policies and that's not going to change
certainly until perhaps november when xi
jinping is rubber stamped in to a lead
for life so the doors are closed really
here in terms of how much john lee can
do because the mainland border has to
open with china before it can open to
international travel and he himself and
the current administration have admitted
that so hong kong's going to be cut off
for some time yet
well amid all of that i see in his
44-page manifesto he vowed to tackle
inequality
unlike previous chief executives he's
not a politician not a civil servant not
from the business world mr gao what do
you make of his ability to address some
of these issues especially given the
context that tom's just
described well that's exactly what i
said that mr lee need to bring hong kong
together
hong kong has huge challenges in terms
of housing jobs for example creativity
and innovation as well as connecting in
a greater depth with china's mainland as
well as with the rest of the world the
world is changing china is changing the
greater bay area is changing hong kong
with all its advantages should adapt to
the changing circumstances rather than
being complacent or rather than being
left behind i think all these need to be
addressed by the new chief executive
therefore i think reaching out to the
rest of the world including the western
world as well as chinese mainland in
particular the greater bay area to
address all these challenges in hong
kong will be mr lee's top priority now
allow me to make one point
we know what the united states now is
dealing with uh january the sixth
insurrection uh occupying the capital of
the united states in washington dc
whatever that happened in hong kong
comparing with the occupation of the
capital city in the united states
really should be judged by the same
light the united states now is accusing
mega as sedition and rebellion as
anarchy as demons as undermining rule of
law we should use the same criteria to
look at those rioters storming the
electrical building setting up arson
attacking police you name it i think
tom i'm going to bring you in because
you were on the ground with the
protesters in the streets during many
many of these days what would you say to
mr gao
um i agree perhaps this time things may
be different because you know
the last five leaders have always said
that they are going to solve the housing
problem and uh inequality you have
rising unemployment this housing crisis
and mass exodus and exports are down
gdp is down um but what you often see
with china and its troublesome periphery
is whether that be taiwan or xinjiang is
that they they try to throw money at the
problem and investment infrastructure
and that kind of thing perhaps
misjudging uh the real root of the issue
and and integration with china is often
the issue in hong kong
uh so maybe it will be different when it
comes to the tycoons and the power they
hold and the housing situation here but
i think the thought in most people heads
today when they see this rather broad
and vague manifesto of glittering
generalities is how is he gonna do it
and is it real this time because they
really have heard it all before in hong
kong when it comes to we're going to
solve the housing crisis
um tommy very briefly mentioned xinjiang
there and i want to bring stephen on
this because mr lee was the one in 2019
who sanctioned the use of water cannon
tear gas even live rounds on protesters
and i see after a visit to xinjiang in
that same year he then told lawmakers
that there could be lessons for hong
kong's own counter-terrorism strategy
what should we be expecting from him
going forward steve
i think that is a very sign
johnny
was a long-standing police officer in
hong kong
he would have joined the police force
probably in the late 70s
and went through the period of the 80s
and 90s
when hong kong's police force
transformed itself when from once that
was systematically corrupt
to becomes the most respected
department in the hong kong government
and when he was
secretary for security in 2019
in a matter of weeks
he adopted tactics that completely
squandered the legacy that the police
built up in the previous quarter of a
century
turning into the most hated and despised
department in the hong kong government
and that is before
he was even referring to xinjiang as
providing inspirational
experience he should look back into the
history of the hong kong police force
where it got things right
where it earned public respect and
credibility
as chief executive he will have to
earn that respect and credibility before
he will have a chance to put his policy
ideas into practice otherwise they are
just slogans
in speaking of policy practices mr gao i
want to ask you because i noticed amid
the trials of those currently being
prosecuted in hong kong under the
national security law which mr lee has
been a big proponent of i see even a
beijing appointed judge has criticized
the delays in terms of process there
could china potentially go too far here
no i think
not why because one thing should be
clear in hong kong
rule of law and democratic rights need
to be fully protected on the other hand
anything which denies china's
sovereignty over hong kong is illegal is
against the national security law and
anything which advocates hong kong
independence for example will be
punished by law this is very similar to
many other countries for example in the
united states they practice a system one
nation under god indivisible no one can
really use force to achieve independence
of any particular state that will be
illegal punishable by law many other
countries have similar things so you
cannot say what's happened in hong kong
under the attack against the hong kong
government attack of the very
well-behaved police force in hong kong
is rule of law is freedom of expression
what happened in washington for example
occupying the capitol hill is illegal no
you should know
and use the same principle and same
benchmark to judge these violations
against the rule of law in the united
states
and in hong kong thank you mr gala i
want to bring in tom here because he is
on the ground in hong kong and i i don't
want to let you go without asking you
about public sentiment there now it's
been a while i believe since we've had
any solid poll figures but by last count
it looks like support for the opposition
movement has increased but then support
for protests has decreased we've
obviously seen very few people out on
the streets there have been covert
restrictions in place now given the low
turnout that we also saw in the december
elections as well record low turnout do
people even care who's in charge now or
is this a done deal for beijing it
really struck me in the story we saw
earlier from adrian that level of apathy
is it apathy tom or is it submission
it's difficult to tell because most of
the democrats are behind bars in exile
or of quick politics and i think if
anything it is more about fear the big
thing victor gets wrong there is that
actually in the us you will not go to
prison for your words
for waving a flag for a sticker
advocating independence these are the
kinds of things that people have been
prosecuted for and that's what's keeping
people off the street if you do want to
look at any statistics well the last
time they surveyed um
approval ratings john lee had a a
favorable rating of about 37
and he has promised a local version of a
national security law which last time
um that was tabled in 2003 brought half
a million people onto the streets again
i don't think you're gonna see the kind
of mass protests you did in 2019 or back
then um but certainly i think what's
keeping people off the streets at the
moment is the national security law and
how effective it has been i guess in
quoting uh defense
well we'll certainly be watching how
this all plays out in the coming days
weeks and months but for now we'll leave
our discussion there thank you to all of
our guests tom grundy victor gao and
steve sang
and thank you two for watching you can
see this program again any time by
visiting our website that's
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
do go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story and remember you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside story from me anastasia tay
and the whole team here in doha bye for
now
you